un anuncio que pone fin a meses de
especulación dijo
el comité olímpico y el comité
paralímpico junto a japón y en línea con
las restricciones del gobierno para
eventos multitudinarios tanda yoga y
cantor y tarimas hemos decidido
establecer el límite de espectadores en
el 50 por ciento de la capacidad de los
estadios hasta un máximo de 10.000
espectadores a 'jojoy' de can que access
no lleguen mod
la decisión llega pocas semanas antes de
la ceremonia de apertura prevista para
el 23 de julio sin embargo el comité
organizador de las justas advirtió que
la competencia deportiva podría
realizarse a puerta cerrada si hay un
repunte en las infecciones y habrá
estrictas restricciones la asistencia de
espectadores extranjeros sigue prohibida
y a los locales que asistan se les
exigirá el porte de mascarillas no
podrán gritar durante los eventos
deportivos y sólo podrán desplazarse
entre las sedes olímpicas y sus hogares
en las calles de tokio las opiniones
están divididas
yo también creo que los espectadores son
necesarios para motivar los atletas
mientras pensemos en la seguridad y
podamos evitar los grupos creo que está
bien celebrar los juegos
[Música]
algunos jóvenes corren el riesgo de
sufrir complicaciones y todavía no todos
han recibido la vacuna entonces desde
ese punto de vista creo que deberíamos
evitar crear multitudes
así como los asistentes los atletas
también tendrán que cumplir con ciertas
restricciones se les prohibirá el
contacto con el público y corren el
riesgo de ser expulsados de los juegos y
violan las reglas incluido del uso de
mascarilla y las pruebas diarias de kobe
19 japón ha visto un brote del virus
relativamente pequeño con casi 14 mil
500 muertes por corona virus sin embargo
el avance del programa de vacunación ha
sido lento el temor a que los olímpicos
generen rebrotes ha hecho que hasta un
65% de los japoneses pidan que los
juegos sean pospuestos o simplemente
cancelados